[Music]
workers unlock the top of the still and
pour in chlorine free deionized water
[Music]
once the still is one-quarter full they
add the lemongrass they stack the
bundles in a crisscross fashion creating
gaps for steam to pass through they
screw the lid tightly to prevent the
loss of steam during distillation they
activate the still and it heats the
water to the boiling point steam rises
through the plants and picks up the oils
it carries the oil vapor up through a
pipe and into a condenser where the
vapors cool and return to a liquid form
the liquid oil and water drip out into a
flask oil and water don't mix so the oil
floats to the top and the water is
drained off and recycled back into the
distiller
the technician then collects the
lemongrass oil in a bottle one drop at a
time the lemongrass oil undergoes a
second distillation in a laboratory
using a more sensitive piece of
equipment known as a rotary vacuum
evaporator the oil flows into a flask
that's spinning in a hot bath of
vegetable oil the evaporator pumps out
air and creates a vacuum in the flask
which lowers the boiling point this
prevents damage to the delicate
molecules responsible for the lemongrass
scent the oil vapors rise to a condenser
coil where they reel iqua PHY leaving
any residual water and impurities behind
the pure lemongrass oil drips into a
receiver flask as distilled lemongrass
oil is collected more flows into the
evaporator beaker for purification
the distilling process is continuous the
rotary vacuum evaporator processes
roughly two to three quarts of fragrant
oil per hour they store the lemongrass
oil in a cold room with other essential
oils like fine wine it must be kept cool
or it could spoil and ruin its bouquet
[Music]